Determina el máximo factor común de estos monomios.
Ok, aquí el máximo factor común es el factor más grande que esté en ambos monomios,
hay que tener un poquito de cuidado con
máximo le voy a poner comillas, con "máximo" en este contexto
porque es máximo en el sentido de tener la mayor cantidad de factores que estén en ambos números
pero en tamaño quien sabe, porque depende de las variables, a lo mejor "c" es negativa
o a lo mejor "d" es menor que 1 y su cuadrado la hace más chiquita
bueno, eso es meterse con los detallitos.
Mejor ahorita vamos a hacer el proceso para ver pues cómo funciona esta cosa ¿Vale?
Y el proceso consiste en lo siguiente.
Lo primero que tenemos que hacer es partir cada uno de los monomios en su factorización en primos,
que básicamente es una
combinación de la factorización en primos de los números, y de la factorización de la parte variable ¿Va?
Bueno déjame hacer eso, para el primer monomio vamos con este 10,
este 10 su factorización en primos es 2 por 5.
¿Ok? Hasta ahí dejamos el 10 y ahora pasamos a los demás.
Esta "c",
esta "c" simplemente es una "c"
esa "c"no está siendo multiplicada por nada y su exponente es 1
entonces, simplemente queda como una "c", y finalmente esta "d"
esta "d" es "d" al cuadrado entonces, la partimos como "d" por "d" ¿Vale?
"d" al cuadrado es lo mismo que "d" por "d".
Vamos a hacer lo mismo aquí abajo el 25, el 25 es 5 por 5
5 por 5, aquí tenemos "c" al cubo entonces "c" al cubo es
"c" por "c" por "c" y aquí abajo tenemos "d" cuadrada, déjame ponerle por "d"
por "d" ¡Muy bien! Entonces esto de aquí es justo lo que te digo, es como una combinación
de la factorización en primos del número, con la factorización de la parte variable,
donde simplemente lo que estamos haciendo es que los exponentes
los estamos separando en cachitos, en cada uno de sus factores.
¡Muy bien! Ahora sí.
¿Cómo calculamos el máximo común factor de los monomios?
Pues vemos cuáles de estos números y variables están en ambos.
Por ejemplo para la parte numérica tenemos que el 5, déjame agarrar un color
que he usado, el amarillo, por ejemplo, el 5 está aquí y también está aquí entonces, el 5 es
la parte común en la parte numérica
con la "c", pues tenemos una "c" en común nada más,
no hay 2 "c" acá arriba ¿Va? Y con las "d" pues tenemos estas 2 "d" en común,
estas dos "d" en común. Ahora sí lo que hacemos para encontrar el máximo común factor es
multiplicar estos factores que tienen en común entonces, el máximo
común factor de estos números simplemente es 5
5 por "c" por "d"
por "d" pero lo voy a poner por "d" cuadrada ¿Sale? "D" por "d" es "d" cuadrada.
Otra vez, entonces esto de aquí es el máximo común factor,
no en un sentido de tamaño, tendríamos que ver si "c" es positiva o negativa o si "d" es mayor o menor que 1
pero, es más bien máximo en un sentido en el,
en el que divide a ambos, en el sentido de que divide a ambos monomios y además
es la expresión que tiene la mayor cantidad de factores de ambos.